(audience clapping)
- Yes. That's stunning.
- Well, thank you.
- I was like, I love the color.
- Our shoes match a bit.
- Yes!
- [Kelly] I know.
It actually goes quite well,
the plum and the yellow. I like it.
I heard that you were also
raised in Texas, is it Houston?
- Yes! Yes, yes, yes!
- [Kelly] Yeah, I didn't know that.
- You're Fort Worth?
(audience claps)
- I'm Fort Worth, yeah
- That's so funny.
Yeah, I moved to Texas, to Houston
when I was almost six years old.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah, wow
- [Anna] Yeah.
- That's a big move.
I actually did a big move like
that around six years old.
- Yeah?
- That's tough.
I moved from, well, from
Texas to California for a bit
and then we moved back to Texas.
That was kind of a weird age to move.
- Yeah, six is a weird age, I think,
'cause you like, you know you're
coming out of being a baby
into like kind of forming a real identity.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- So it's an interesting...
- Finding your first
friendships and like school...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What was your move like?
That must have been a shock.
Where did you move from?
- Well You know, I moved
from Dakar, Senegal,
so that was very different.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- To Houston, Texas.
- A little different
from California to Texas.
- [Anna] A little different,
a little different
(Kelly laughs)
Yeah. My mother, she moved me out there,
my dad was already there and so,
you know but it was very lonely,
it was very confusing.
it's like a different
language, a different...
- [Kelly] That's a lot. Yeah.
- world, so yeah
- [Kelly] I mean, you did well.
- Thanks.
- [Kelly] But yeah, that's a lot.
So you grew up, is it with two brothers?
- Mmm. Yes.
- [Kelly] What was the, oh, with the mmm
(laughter)
- Already said it all
- I always say I was raised
by wolves. Just like...
(audience laughs)
two boys, you know.
My older brother he's,
always been very macho,
very physical, very, he ended
up being a marine sniper.
- [Kelly] Wow!
- Shout out to Badu.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- But yeah, he would like
toughen me up, you know?
He wanted to prepare me for life
in the world and so he would physically,
like really challenge me
sometimes, and like...
- Is that like just a nice
way of saying you fought?
- [Anna] Yes!
(everyone laughs)
- [Kelly] Okay. I was like...
Basically he challenged me,
and then I terrorize my little
brother Kareem for years.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. Well
it's a family tradition
- Until I got home one day and
Kareem was too big for me to beat him up.
(Kelly laughing)
But yeah.
- I love that, I love the
toughening, that's love.
It's some guys' love language.
(audience cheering)
The new movie is called Nanny.
It's a horror thriller, right?
- It is, it is.
You know, people see it
and they have kind of different
definitions of it, um...
- 'Cause I'm into thriller,
but horror not so much.
- No, you'll be okay.
(audience laughing)
You'll be okay.
- [Kelly] Okay
- It's not like that crazy body horror
or too many crazy jump scares.
- [Kelly] Okay
- It's more psychological.
It's more
(clicks her tongue)
- Okay, I like the attitude in that scene.
- Yeah.
- Well, how you think she'd been eatin'?
- Aisha.
- [Kelly] I like that. I like that
- Yeah yeah yeah that Aisha.
So I play Aisha who's a mother.
She leaves Senegal, where I'm also from.
And she moves to New York.
And when we meet her at
the beginning of the film
she's been in New York for almost a year.
And she's trying to save up
money to bring her son back.
She herself is undocumented,
so she has to take on
the kind of work that a lot of immigrants
and undocumented people have to take on.
- And have to stay in situations
that you don't want to
- Domestic work, you know,
situations that are quite
exploitive sometimes.
And so she gets a job as a nanny
and she's really grateful for
it and excited for the job.
But then things turn out
to not be as they seem
and we just follow her journey
through this experience.
- Oh OK, I might watch it now.
(audience laughs)
- [Anna] Please do.
- Okay I always, I just
told her right before,
I was like I always feel bad
when people come out
with horror films here.
'cause I'm like, usually
I watch everything,
but I'm terrified of horror.
- Well you know what,
it's a story about...
- [Kelly] If it's more
thriller I can take it.
- It's more thriller and
it's really really, it's just
a human story about motherhood
and survival and resilience.
- So like any day that ends in y.
(Kelly and crowd laughing)
- Exactly.
- [Kelly] Being a mother.
- Yeah. Yeah exactly
- Okay, I'm excited about
it. You've now sold me.
I was very scared at first.
I was like, how do I tell
her I can't watch horror?
(Kelly and Anna talking at the same time)
- I promise you'll be okay.
- [Kelly] Okay. I'm excited
about, I like that scene.
So that was a good tease.
So there are some evil
spirits in this movie.
Does your mother believe in evil spirits?
Is that what I hear?
- She does.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- My mother's a very
cautious woman you know,
She, growing up in Senegal,
there's a lot of
mysticism and spirituality
that plays a part of the
culture in a real way.
So she's like this water for example,
she'll take it to one of our
spiritual leaders in Senegal,
they're called marabouts,
and she'll take it and they'll
pray over a certain item
either a piece of clothing
or some water or something
and she'll bring back
the water and she's like,
drink this and rub it all over yourself
and your husband will come".
And I'm like, "Okay mom"
(Anna and crowd laughing)
I will try that. But she
really much believes in...
- Right now around the nation
people are like getting water
blessed and like, here we go.
- Yeah
Go to Senegal, find a marabout,
they'll pray over some something for you
and follow their instructions
and hopefully it'll...
- Are you, do you like that?
I think, I think that there's
some beauty in that kind
of spirituality and spirits
and stuff like that.
I can respect that.
- Yeah, there's lot of
symbolism in it too, right?
And I think it's, it's all about intention
and they do it with intention.
- And manifesting and yeah
- Exactly. So I do believe
in it, in that sense
- I thought it was really cool.
I heard about that and I was
like, I gotta ask about that.
- Yeah.
- Did your family believe
in like supernatural stuff growing up?
- Not really.
I mean, I also have a
profound respect for it,
especially when anybody,
a group of people's putting
energy into one thing.
I do think like, I don't
believe necessarily in spirits,
but I think it can change the
benefits of like the water.
You know what I mean?
- I 100% agree
- But like when I was little, my sisters,
we used to play Bloody
Mary in the bathroom
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah
- when I was like really little
and then we were looking in the mirror
and the lights are off and they'd be like,
Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary.
And then they hand you the baby
and every, 'cause I was the littlest again
when they'd hand me the baby,
I'd be like, oh oh, I got it
and they'd be like,
(Kristen gasps)
You dropped it!
And I'm like no I didn't, no I didn't
And they'd be like you're gonna
die in your sleep tonight!
(everyone laughs)
So I guess at an early age
I hit a point of going, that's (beep)
(everyone laughs)
I didn't die in my sleep"
- I did not drop the baby.
- Number 1, I didn't drop the baby.
Number 2, I didn't die in my sleep
so I'm not buying your stuff.
- But when you're little, that's the thing
when you're the youngest,
people they'll just
terrify you and, you take it
'cause you don't know any different.
- You believe it
- 100%
- Ah, anyway, older siblings.